kondensstreifen schaden dem klima
erheblich bis 2050 wird sie hier
klimaeffekt sogar verdreifachen
der flugverkehr verursacht ja schon
horrenden co2 emissionen und andere
treibhausgase die das klima nachhaltig
schädigen und die erderwärmung antreiben
doch auch die kondensstreifen die beim
fliegen am himmel entstehen sind nicht
ohne ein deutsches forschungsteam hat
jetzt herausgefunden dass der durch
kondensstreifen verursachte klimaeffekt
eben sich bis zum jahr 2050
verdreifachen wird das problem wird also
immer größer klicks um science-fiction
hier gibt es täglich spannende science
videos aber auch bei breaking lab
abonniert den kanal nur dann verpasst ja
nichts herzlich willkommen um das rätsel
zu lösen klicks um science-fiction heute
in kooperation mit breaking lab also
jakob übernehme
wie sehen eigentlich ziemlich harmlos
aus sind aber alles andere als dass
kondensstreifen gemeint sind damit die
langen schmalen weißen streifen die
flugzeuge am blauen himmel hinterlassen
chemisch gesehen handelt es sich dabei
um langgezogene eiswolken in einer
flughöhe von bis zu 10.000 metern
herrschen etwa minus 40 grad celsius bei
der verbrennung von kerosin entstehen
abgase wie ruß und andere schwebstoffe
die somit in die atmosphäre gelangen sie
werden in der fachsprache auch als
kristallisationskeime bezeichnet denn an
diesen partikeln lagern sich zunächst
wassermoleküle ab die dann zu
eiskristallen werden diese sehen wir
dann in form von sichtbaren eiswolken
manchmal können diese kondensstreifen
aber auch zu weißlich fein
strukturierten schleierwolken
heranwachsen die man in der fachsprache
dann als zirn bezeichnet diese können
sogar tagelang haben will bleiben und
das bleibt nicht ohne folgen denn sie
versperren der wärmestrahlung ihren weg
zurück ins weltall china
heißt also im klartext wärme die vom
erdboden aufsteigt wird wieder nach
unten reflektiert oder halt absorbiert
die folge die obere erdatmosphäre
erwärmt sich und dieser effekt hat
enorme folgen diese wollten bildung ist
ein echter klimakiller deutlich mehr
sogar als das co2 das durch flugzeuge
in derselben zeit ausgestoßen wird und
so trägt nach schätzungen des
weltklimarats der weltweite flugverkehr
mit etwa fünf prozent zum
menschengemachten erderwärmung bei das
ist eine menge und vor allem weitaus
mehr als von der luftfahrtindustrie
immer wieder gesagt wird doch vielleicht
nicht genug genau davor warnt jetzt ein
forschungsteam des deutschen zentrum für
luft und raumfahrt aus köln denn die
entwicklung des weltweiten flug auf
kommt wird sich aktuellen prognosen
zufolge alle 15 jahre verdoppeln
vom jahr 2006 bis zum jahr 2050 würde
sich also vervierfachen in ihrer studie
interessierten sich die drei atmosphären
forscherinnen vor allem für die
auswirkungen der kondensstreifen auf die
strahlungsbilanz und den daraus
resultierenden temperaturveränderungen
am boden als basis zogen sie dazu ein
globales atmosphären modell heran das in
dem ein szenario von einer mässigen
erwärmung der erde ausgeht und in einem
anderen szenario von einer drastischen
erwärmung und das ergebnis der fachleute
ist erschreckend der aktuellen studie
zufolge wird sich der klimaeffekt durch
kondensstreifen mit dem zunehmend
flugverkehr bis zum jahr 2050 etwa
verdreifachen die aktuellen berechnungen
beruhen auf vielen verschiedenen
annahmen unter anderem gehen fachleute
davon aus dass vor allem der flugverkehr
in afrika und südostasien extrem
zunehmen wird technische entwicklung
werden in den nächsten jahren zudem dazu
führen dass der trend hin zu steigenden
flughöhen geht auch das hat folgen auf
die bildung von kondensstreifen denn
größere höhen führen dazu dass nicht nur
der luftwiderstand sondern auch der
treibstoffverbrauch abnimmt entscheidend
für die bildung von kondensstreifen das
allerdings auch die luftfeuchtigkeit
relativ gesehen würde so in den
gemäßigten breiten weniger
kondensstreifen entstehen bedingt durch
eine geringere luftfeuchtigkeit der
aktuellen studie zufolge könnte sich der
strahlungs antrieb also das ist die
energie die von außen auf die erde
konnte energie
lanz pro quadratmeter die könnte sich
bis zum jahr 2050 sogar um 48 prozent
reduziert der anstieg der flughöhe würde
in regionen mit einer hohen
luftfeuchtigkeit aber für einen
gegenteiligen effekt sorgen die bildung
von zirruswolken nämlich auf den punkt
gebracht gehen die drei autorinnen der
aktuellen studie davon aus dass vor
allem über asien ein anstieg der
kondensstreifen zu erwarten ist
fachleute sind sich übrigens bislang
noch nicht ganz einig wie viel stärker
sich kondensstreifen tatsächlich auf den
klimawandel auswirken klar ist dass sich
die obere atmosphäre durch die menschen
verursachten wolken aufweist denn die
kondensstreifen sorgen zum einen dafür
dass die wärme die von der erde
aufsteigt zurück reflektiert wird wie in
einem treibhaus eben doch die wolken
haben zum anderen wohl auch noch einen
anderen effekt denn sie filtern die
sonneneinstrahlung zumindest zum teil
auch ab und kühlen so die atmosphäre
doch welcher effekt ist größer aktuelle
forschungsarbeiten legen nahe dass die
wärmende wirkung die kühlende im mittel
überwiegt da zu dieser bock vom dlr
die kondensstreifen sowie ihre einflüsse
auf die erdoberfläche sind laufende
forschungsthemen bisher gibt es noch
große unsicherheiten über die gesamte
klima auswirkungen dieser wolken
insbesondere bezüglich ihrer
auswirkungen auf oberflächentemperatur
aber eines ist klar
sie erwärmen die atmosphäre laut der
aktuellen studie ist es dringend
notwendig emissionsarmes fliegen durch
technische innovationen schnell möglich
zu machen denn dadurch könnte letzten
endes auch die bildung von
kondensstreifen vermindert werden denn
schließlich hängen größe und anzahl der
eiskristalle von den rußpartikel
emissionen der flugzeug antriebs werke
ab doch selbst die reduktion von ruß
emission könnte längst nicht mehr
ausreichend seien
dazu die wissenschaftlerin ulrike
burkhardt selbst wenn ein 90 prozentiger
rückgang der emittierten partikel
gelingt wird es wahrscheinlich nicht
ausreichen um die klima auswirkungen von
kondensstreifen auf das niveau von 2006
zu begrenzen die autorinnen der
aktuellen studie haben zudem eine klare
forderung sie kritisieren dass die
auswirkungen von kondensstreifen auf das
globale klimasystem bislang noch nicht
in emission
nur abkommen berücksichtigt werden dazu
dieser bock es ist aber wichtig die
signifikante auswirkungen von nicht co2
emissionen den kondensstreifen zirren
auch das klima zu untersuchen auch diese
effekte müssen bei der einrichtung von
emissionshandel systemen berücksichtigt
werden ja vielen dank jakob und eine
ganz andere frage ist noch sind
kondensstreifen chemtrails geht von
ihnen eine chemische gefahr aus breaking
lab mit jakob hat dazu intensiv
recherchiert und die ein oder andere
überraschende antwort anklicken also
hier anschauen und unbedingt breaking
lab abonnieren da mal kanal es lohnt
sich bis dann bleibt dran